live from the headquarters of Ramsey
solutions it's the Dave Ramsey show
we're dead is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the BMW as the status symbol of
choice I'm in the lobby of our
headquarters to announce a brand new
thingy
streamers are flying down from above
money is flying down from above on the
lobby the people in the lobby here are
being showered with confetti they're
being showered with money it's happening
people this is real a man I'll tell you
what this is a blast unbelievable well
absolutely amazing a huge launch there's
dollars all over the floor kids are
scrambling to get richer a few adults
are scrambling to get richer money is
coming down from up above it's coming
from the balcony actually this is pretty
cool you guys so what in the world is
going on in the lobby of Ramsey
solutions why are we out here letting it
rain money down why are we doing this
why have all these people gathered why
is our whole team looking in from
windows above from the parking lot out
back because today as of that banner
being busted open officially three years
and three and a half million dollars
worth of work has come together and we
are launching today the world's best bar
none on line budgeting tool and it's
called every dollar and you can see the
little logo right here goes with a
hoodie sweatshirt it's called every
dollar because we've taught you for the
last 25 years to give every dollar a
name now a pen and paper that's a good
way to give every dollar a name and I've
taught you to do that in financial peace
university since back in the VHS days
and then some of you graduated without
my permission but you did the
spreadsheets some of you have tried
online tools that you didn't really use
or you used part of them because they
didn't work and they didn't do what they
were supposed to do instead we've taken
our principles showing you how to do a
budget showing you how to give every
dollar a name integrating the baby steps
integrating all the processes in the
encouragement and the education and the
entertainment that we use here to teach
you and lift you and it's all integrated
into literally the world's best online
budgeting tool there is no better it's
absolutely incredible and here's the
best part get this you ready get this
it's free
so Wow it's free and so if you don't
like it will cut the price in half it's
free you're going to love this thing and
the iphone app that you can use to
manage your expenses once you get your
budget set up is free it's completely
free we've managed to figure out a
business model to work this thing or
literally tens of millions of people can
use it and we'll be able to monetize and
be able to work on it and give it to you
for free it's absolutely incredible now
if you want to hook up to your bank and
have the expenses automatically download
like like so you go out to eat and get a
hamburger and you put that on your debit
card and you want that to show up on
your iPhone and automatically prompt you
and then you grab it on your iPhone and
you drag it up into restaurants and a
drop right there now if you want that
connectivity your bank we have to pay
for that so you'll have to pay us a
little bit of an upgrade that's called
plus but if you don't wanna do that it's
free it's absolutely free and it is
incredible the things that this thing
will do the way it walks you through the
baby steps the way it prompts you it's
not just a glorified spreadsheet with
some nice graphics on it these guys on
our team have spent as I said three
years three and a half million dollars
plus or minus that probably a little
more than that actually if I count all
the costs but working on this thing and
they have done an incredible job now the
web guys they've taught me new new words
that I didn't know apparently this thing
is robust I didn't know that and that
means that it'll do all kinds of stuff
that you didn't even dream it would do
and you're only gonna have to get in
there and learn about all the things
that will do its massive and it we're
going to continue to iterate it which I
have learned that that means we're going
to continue working on it and making it
better as we go along and apparently
it's elegant now i dunno what that is
because it's beautiful so shut up so
what's it called its called every dollar
and you can go to dave ramsey calm right
now and learn about it or you can go to
every dollar calm anytime you want for
the rest of your life and you can get it
for free and you can go get the app for
your Apple iPhone and get it for free
and you'll build them categorize your
expenses it won't do it for you I didn't
want it to do it for you it's a
our principles for you to not have to
manage your money stuff that
automatically manages all your money for
you you lose touch with your money you
lose a feel of it and your money will
leave those of you that manage money
know how important it is to manage it
you remember when you wrote down that
budget how you could feel those numbers
the first time we wanted that same kind
of psychology that same kind of spirit
over every dollar so that as you fill
out your budget as you set it up yes you
can copy last month and move it forward
so some of the things are repetitive
right make it easy we won't make you do
all the hard work every single month but
we want you having your finger in there
dragging that expense around and moving
those things and making those decisions
yourself to where you are actually
feeling and managing your money it is
absolutely necessary now look at the
vice president of every dollar that has
been running this whole project is here
with me ladies and gentleman give
Michael Finney a huge round of applause
gratulations got some got some fistfuls
of money down here Michael how how
satisfying is it to launch this thing I
know you guys just had a baby and you
got another one on the way and all this
kind of stuff i mean so I've had kids
and grandkids that's pretty satisfying
from a business perspective after three
and a half years it's like having an
elephant yeah it doesn't get any better
than this I mean when we looked at it a
few years ago and said man dave has
always said give every single dollar a
name before the month begins and then
you look at the existing tools out there
and it makes it hard to do and it's got
like these 50 minutes you know set up
processes every dollar is so drop dead
simple from conception all the way
through to be here today is phenomenal
the amount of work you know is speaking
if you're going to do a speaking gig if
you want to make something simple you
have to be really good at it if you're
not really good at you is made
complicated and then people don't know
you're not good at it in this case what
we had to do is we had to be so good at
not only budgeting but also integrating
those budget principles we would be so
good at programming and so good at
building and so good at the the web
architecture and the development
architecture of the whole project in
order to make the end user make it
really simple for them so you guys
worked your butt off so they don't have
to that's what comes down to it yeah
absolutely I mean before we even you
know started building this the first
thing we did was build a prototype
went over to the mall and we had you
know like 300 people tested over in the
mall you know over a three-day period we
just said hey what do you like about
this what do you not like about this
we've been iterating on it iterating on
it and then once we kind of got to those
core set of principles and we said okay
this is what it's going to look like
then to take that and to go build it so
that millions of people could use it
make sure it's going to stay up and
running and be efficient for people I
mean huge Indian in 30 seconds what do
you want people this is your baby what
do you want people to get from every
dollar I want people to realize how easy
it is to do a budget I mean it's not you
you always say it's like sixth grade
math it's not hard to do and a lot of
other tools out there have made it hard
to do there you go folks that's it every
dollar ladies and gentlemen go to every
dollar calm it's loud baby
you